hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in a short essay
art and anti-art
George Dickey is going to provide us
with a way of understanding something
that that arises quite often within the
field of art I'm also designed and all
the conversations surrounding at it that
we can call aesthetics in a very broad
sense this notion of anti-art
is relatively new on the scene there
have been attempts to try to define art
as a practice and a product going back
millennia as a matter of fact that's one
part of aesthetics is it not and within
say the the end of the 19th the 20th
century and well into our current 21st
century there's been a lot of emphasis
on subverting the conventions of art and
producing something that would as people
I say push the envelope get outside of
the box do something new and creativity
has been often framed as as a central
part of this so by being creative you go
against what counts as art you do
something different you know we might
think in music about the whole
DIY and punk ethos that very quickly was
assimilated right back into the music
scene but gives rise to garage bands
every once in a while and we could come
up with all sorts of interesting
examples so Dickie is interested in this
notion of auntie art and what its
relation is with art now he is going to
frame this in terms of what he calls an
institutional definition of art
something that's a different theory than
the earlier ones which tended to frame
art in terms of imitation or
representation on the one hand you might
think about going all the way back to
Plato and Republic book 10 and all those
discussions or Aristotle and his
discussion of a maysa in the poetics all
the way into the art as expression
period or art as something that would
connect us together and Dickie is going
to take a you might say more
sociological view on it which views
things is taking place through what he
calls an art world taking that term as
he mentions from arthur danto so what we
have here is a he says a focus on the
social framework in which particular
works are embedded and get to be called
art so what is this art world idea I'm
going to talk about this at greater
length elsewhere in reference to some of
his other writings but here's the the
core that he summarizes here in this
article he says that it consists of a
corps of creators presenters and
appreciators which is then surrounded by
critics theorists and philosophers of
art and it also includes all the
machinery required to present works of
art so what are these three classes of
creators presenters and appreciators
here's some examples painters writers
actors sculptors you know
and anybody else who are going to
include presenters would be museum
directors gallery managers to some
degree musicians actors in a different
sense he says than those above we might
also think about you know dual roles
where somebody is a film director right
as being part of that and then finally
we have the appreciators the people who
actually go and consume the art and view
it as art and probably play some role in
communicating their tastes to others the
museum goers concert goers theater goers
what is the apparatus required he says
museums concert halls art galleries
theaters walls of houses today we might
extend this to a whole bevy of websites
as well you know so for example think
about how artists have their works on
Instagram as well as their own gallery
page as well as maybe Pinterest or
something like that all of that is part
of the art world and he says critics are
also part of that philosophers of art
are also part of that so you know it's
it's a very wide framework and we don't
necessarily need to draw rigid lines and
say well here is where the art world
ends and here's where something else
begins because it's not like that it's
more like a network so this is going to
help us in defining what's going on with
aunty art now the institutional
definition of art basically says what is
art art is what the art world considers
to be art what the art world takes
seriously enough to call art and this is
you know where we find rebuttals to the
people who go into an art museum and
they look at a Pollock painting and
they're like my kid could do that well
your kids not Pollock right the art
world doesn't deem what your kid does in
splattering paint all around to be and
any art worth talking about they might
call it lowercase a art but they take
Pollock seriously similarly when cage
silence as part of a musical composition
that's not the same thing as you sitting
in your garage not doing anything right
why because the art world in it's not
infinite wisdom but whatever wisdom it
possesses has deemed one thing arts and
another thing not so this this idea has
been around for quite a while right
and you could see auntie art as a way of
kind of you know thumbing your nose at
these conventions of what counts as art
and what doesn't count as art and Dicky
says I'm going to talk about four main
sorts of things that we can call anti
art the expression itself is he says is
both slippery and robbery slippery
sometimes it means one thing and
sometimes another distinguishing for
different types of things will help with
that
rubbery sometimes it and its opposite
are predicated at the same time so
sometimes something is called a work of
an anti art and it's also called a work
of art again his classification and
analysis will help us understand that so
what are the four types we have art in
which chance plays a part you might
think about the automatic writing or you
know people like dripping things
randomly onto canvases or setting up a
computer program to randomly punch holes
in a card or anything along those lines
as a matter of fact some of the things
like let's say I fill up my mouth with
you know die and I spit it out onto a
t-shirt right and it's kind of random
where you know my teeth and tongue and
lips all determine where that that
splatter of yellow or green this is kind
of oh right
and we we say okay well that's not the
same thing as art and the artist can say
yeah I'm like subverting things man
I'm going against the intentionality of
art I'm using randomness to do something
here okay there there been a lot of
compositions done like that art which
has as he calls it strikingly unusual
content this is a rather relative term
isn't it art that has striking the
unusual content you know if if we depict
figurative things that usually aren't
looked at as being worthy of artistic
representation that's strikingly unusual
content until it's not right or we might
use different media you know I'm gonna
do a drawing of ants but I'm gonna do it
by using ink that is derived from
grinding up ants I guess that's unusual
content and we can come up with all
sorts of examples of that as well the
idea there is that I'm doing something
that goes beyond the the normal in the
art world and therefore it's an T art
then we have ready-mades this is where
somebody takes something like for
example this tie and you know puts it
inside of a frame or on a wall and says
here you go this is a work of art time
number 15 or red tie or let's call it
oceans because that's a pocket of a
something right and people have been
doing this for quite a while right
he brings up Marcel Duchamp who famously
would take you know things like urinals
and put them in a museum and say aha
work of art right is that a work of art
or is it a work of ante art is he sort
of thumbing his nose at the art
establishment by doing so then we have
actions that are done by artists and he
he's got this great example here of the
New York artist Vito a Conchie who
periodically notifies the art world by
mail that on certain
ates he will mount a stool in his studio
X number of times and that this work may
be viewed at the designated hours he
also did other works in quotes and like
counting his pulse beats and moving the
contents of his apartment to an art
gallery you know we might think of you
know taking the video of somebody
picking their nose if they're an artist
so I said well this is performance art
right and this is easily recognizable to
us now in the 21st century is something
that's been done many many times right
but it was conceived of as being an T
art as doing something different than
creating a painting that you know and an
artists are continually trying to push
the envelope in new media as a matter of
fact we just watched a old episode of
house in which there was a performance
artist who is making a performance out
of her medical diagnosis and all of that
and you know you can do any sort of
thing along those lines and cuff you say
that's a anti art now Dickey goes on and
he says that the first two kinds of ante
art works which employ chants and works
with bizarre content raise no
theoretical problems they're easily
assimilated developments within art so
they're easy to suck back in and you
know you let a decade pass and what was
the revolutionary ante art of the past
people I call halt yes I've seen that
all before
that's so 1994 now we're on to this
whether it be art in which chance plays
a part or art that has strikingly
unusual content ready mates presents a
somewhat different and more rich problem
he goes on and he says that with them
something strange has happened and he
goes on and he says that
how can a ready-made which certainly
seems entitled to the label auntie art
because it's senseless to contemplate it
nevertheless be a work of art the answer
is reference to the institutional
definition of art he says that duchamp's
ready-mades acquired the status of art
because of his declarations now here he
makes a differentiation his non public
behind the hand stressing x' to his
chuckling cohorts that his ready-mades
were not art had no effect the large
public was willing to say well I don't
quite understand this but I guess it's
in a museum so I guess it's arts
everybody else you know who is in the in
the joke right there oh no no look at
these stupid people they think that this
is art and eventually it becomes art and
there's kind of an interesting dynamic
here where things that are being
presented in this ready-made fashion as
like found objects quickly just become
another genre of art that we recognize
as arts and art that's you know only
important because it's it's within the
institutional structure he says that the
relation of his public declaration his
privates dressings is rather like the
relation of testimony under oath to
gossip under the gatepost it's a
testimony that actually counts so what
about the fourth type of anti art here
this has a bit of a better candidacy to
remain anti art he says let's consider
the anti art of a Conchie and friends
these artists go Duchamp one better they
perform an action and make a declaration
but they don't produce that is end up
with an object which in any way
resembles traditional paintings or
sculptures so they may end up with a
video or they may end up with the only
thing that's left behind being a
postcard or the costume that they wore
or something along those lines and then
that is placed within a museum context
or put online or whatever it's going to
be may be retained only in our our minds
so he says the only thing left to do is
for an artist let's call them zero to
make a declaration and not do anything
now here's where it gets really
interesting in terms of analysis this is
what Dickey says a cone she is
exercising the machinery of the art
world and conferring the status of art
on something which is radically
different from traditional paintings and
sculptures and even radically different
from ready-mades what is he doing here
he calls this a mere exercising of the
machinery of the art world he's using
the art world's machinery of museums and
you know art history classes and blogs
about arts and all these sorts of things
to make something that we wouldn't
normally think of his art into an T art
that also becomes art so he goes on and
he says that a koan cheese art is real
an T art why art because they use the
framework of the art world an T because
they do nothing with it they don't
actually produce something that we can
easily recognize as being art and so if
there's any subversion taking place that
seems to be where it's really happening
ready-mades aren't as subversive as
people think they are you know or doing
strange content is not really that
subversive nor is letting chance decide
all that can be easily sucked right back
into the art world it's a little bit
tougher according to Dickie with these
actions by artists that are turned into
art I don't know if that's still the
case today maybe we've had enough of
performance art and it's publishes a
ssin you know I mentioned you know a
television show
playing around with that as part of its
plot for an episode maybe if you're
doing that it no longer can resist being
sucked back into the notion of art so
you know that's something to consider as
we end with thinking about this this
question that Dicky I think is
illuminated quite well for us what is
aunty art
you